whenever i'm struggling with
procrastination or what i think is
procrastination the first step is to
actually just stick the thing in the
schedule and figure out what what
specifically the next action step
actually is good yeah and i find this a
lot with students
when i'm teaching it's like oh i'm going
to study physiology tomorrow i'm like
okay what hang on
firstly what time oh my god okay fine uh
7 p 7 until 8. all right cool now study
physiology is never going to happen so
like what specifically are you gonna do
it's like okay cool i'll read chapter
four okay cool now within chapter four
reading chapter four in guidance and
horse physiology is never gonna happen
it's too long like
do you wanna pick some questions and
guiding people through that thought
process results in okay fine
tomorrow at 7 pm i'm going to
do questions eight to 13 in this book
does that kind of vibe with your
experience of solving helping solve
procrastination oh yeah i'm going to
give you a big hug from across the ocean
here i've leaned a lot in that book that
you're reading on peter golvitzer's work
on implementation intentions so there's
goal intentions we've spent a lot of
time talking about goals you just told
me you hired a personal trainer to help
you better goals but it sounds like the
trainer also introduced you to
implementation intentions
and they're often framed and and
research shows they're best framed as in
situation x i'll do behavior y to
achieve sub goal z
and and there's other research to show
that when we think about things in the
abstract they seem to belong to tomorrow
there's no sense of urgency to them and
when we think about things concretely
they're they belong to today so you put
those two things together and it says
something about the way the human mind
works that we can well in a sense we can
borrow this notion of nudge right that
we
we move ourselves in the direction of
the way the mind works by saying i'm
going to set a time and a specific
behavior i'm going to make it as
concrete as possible because concrete
goals my brain treats them differently
and
again on implementation intentions also
help us break habits or
establish new habits because we put the
cue for the action into the environment
and not rely on internal cues because
internal cues i've already got my habits
established and the example i constantly
use ali is how years ago i wasn't
flossing my teeth and my dentist told me
that i was developing problems with my
gums not surprisingly because of that
and for whatever reason i brushed my
teeth every day really habitually and i
felt it was an important health habit
but
i resented flossing my teeth i didn't
like it and it was just too much of a
bother but i realized i had to do it
so i made an implementation intention
when i pick up my toothbrush because i
always did
i will put the floss
on the counter when then
when then when i put down my toothbrush
i'll pick up my floss now some of your
listeners might be saying no you should
floss before you brush your teeth i got
there but i needed to bootstrap this
process by saying when then and then it
became a habit to have
there and then i also realized that
flossing actually feels good it wasn't
as aversive as i thought in fact i can't
imagine not flossing now and if i floss
every day now that doesn't mean that
there aren't some days when i'm tired
and a little little timmy little
six-year-old timmy maybe even older than
that will say i don't feel like i don't
want to and i then
i have all sorts of other strategies i
go to like what's the next action just
pick up the floss like and or more
importantly than that going back to our
earlier discussion of meditation
mindfulness a buddhist mindset you you
name it parker palmer because he said
this i can have an emotion
without being that emotion this is
another big personal mantra
yeah i'm having this emotion i don't
want to like i don't want to floss my
teeth i don't have to be that i can work
from other parts of my inner landscape
and my other part of my landscape is i
have a health goal that's important to
me healthy gums flossing a lot one day a
week you floss every day and then i pick
up the floss and i floss right and in a
sense to them not become identified with
a thought but to take it back to where
this part of our conversation began
absolutely implementation intentions
are a great step towards reducing
procrastination but as peter galwitzer
makes clear even some of his papers in
the late 1990s when he was really
starting to roll this stuff out you have
to have a commitment to that goal or
it's not going to work right this no
trick or technique on its own will ever
make a difference if you're not
committed to the goal achievement these
tools serve goal achievement and if
you're not committed at that goal well
nothing magic's gonna happen hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day